في ايران تكثر الاسباب التي تدفع المواطن
الى مغادره البلاد فالوضع المعيشي
والاقتصادي صعب ونظام يواجه الاحتجاجات
ضده بالقمع والقتل الهجره وسيله للهرب لكن
النظام يقف عائقا ايضا ونظمته تقييم
التعليم قررت تعليق اختباري ايلتس حتى
نهايه مارس القادم هذا القرار سيمنع طلاب
من الاختبار المعتمد الدوليا والمعني
بتحديد مستوى اللغه الانجليزيه كشرطن
لدخول الجامعات الاجنبيات المرموقه الخطوه
التي بررها النظام بحجه مراجعه اللوائح
الضمن خطه حكومه رئيسي للحد من نزيف هجره
النخبه وارسائي اسس الهجره العكسيه وعلى
نفس النسق وفيما الماضي امتحان توفل والجي
ار اي وهما امتحاني تعتميدهما الجامعات
الدوليه لقبول الطلاب من مختلف فيها انحاء
العالم والاستكمال
رفعت قبل حوالي شهر التكلفه تكلفه همم
تحرير المؤهلات العلميه
للخريجين عده اضعاف من درجه الزملاء الى
الدكتوره المتخصصه والمهنيه في الجامعات
الحكوميه وترجمه الشهادات والمستندات
الهامه ما كان يكلف الالاف اصبح بعشرات
الملايين التومنات والوضع الاقتصاديه اصلا
من سيئا الى اسوء والعمله في اصعب حالاتها
وفي مستوى هبوط القياسي امام الدولار لكن
على ما يبدو ان هذه القرارات لن تثني
الشباب عن الهجره خصوصا بعد تعديل اسعار
الشهادات والذي عقبه انخفاض كبير في
التسجيل على امتحانات الماجستير والصوره
تبدو اقرب من داخل بيانات مرصد الهجره
الايراني العام الماضي سجلت الاحصاءات
143,000 حاله اللجوء المانيا كانت الوجهه
الرئيسيه احتضنت ثلثه اللاجئين الايرانيين
في عام 2021
طوفان الهجره يعني ان هناك بيئه طارده
والبطاله من اهم الاسباب بالنسبه لطالب
العلم والمهن التخصصيه
وبقارنه صغيره تدلل على ما نقول في 2021
اشارك
636,000 طالب في امتحان القبول لشهاده
الماجستير هذا العدد قل ولم يتجاوز ال
500,000 في 2022
تعكسوا هذه الارقام هشاشه المنظومه
التعليميه والمؤسسيه منذ
1979 وتفسر ايضا محاولات النظام الحثيثه
لعكسها وان باساليب التعجيز كما ذكرنا
دليل اخر على هذه الحقائق ايران وصلت
للمرتبه الرابعه عالميا في هجره طلاب
الاوائل الى امريكا حيث يبقى 90% من
الخريجين في امريكا وبهذه النسبه قد لا
يكون هناك اخرجنا في المستقبل والتحذير من
منظمه الرعايه الصحيه في ايران
القلق ليس فقط من نقص الكفاءات الطبيه
والتمريض والهندسه ولكن ايضا من نقص
العماله الذي يمثل تحديا خطرا في ايران
والخوف من ان تتحول الطائره لجائحه وهنا
وجب التوقف عند هذا الرقم
وعشرون الفا هو عدد الاطباء من اصل
ايرانيين الذين يعملون في الولايات
المتحده منهم 8000 طبيبا وجراح مجموعهم
عادل نحو سته وعشرين في المئه من العاملين
الايرانيين في قطاع الرياح رعايه الصحيه
الامريكيه في عام
عاما والتصريحنا لمسؤول الرعايه الصحيه
محمد رئيس ساده
فالمخصصون مثلا في مجال جراحه القلب قال
لا عددهم كثيرا في وقتا اصبحت امراض القلب
الاكثر شيوعا بين الشباب كنا مجال الطب
ليس الوحيد الذي يهاجر منه المتخصصه
[موسيقى]
سلطان
انا